- I'm Olivia Newman, director
of "Where the Crawdads Sing,"
and this is "Tricks of the Trade."
(light music)
What's funny is,
I have this distinct memory
of hearing her interviewed
about the book on the radio.
And I remember,
as I was listening to
her describe the story,
I just thought, "Oh my god, this is,
this sounds so my kind of world."
And then at the end of the interview,
they mentioned that Reese had
picked it for her book club,
and I just, my heart just
sank because I thought,
"Well, she's gonna go make it into a movie
and I'm gonna read it and I'm gonna wish
that I could turn it into a movie."
Then, fast forward a year or so later,
my agents told me they
were looking for a director
for this book "Where the Crawdads Sing."
"Have you read it?"
I said, "Are you kidding me?
That's been on my top of my shelf to read
and I just, I've been too worried
about my heart getting broken. (laughing)"
But I ready it in two days.
I could not put it down.
And it was exactly what
I expected it to be.
I was do drawn into Kya's story.
Delia's writing was so
lyrical and evocative
and really put me in
this very specific place
through the eyes of a character
that I had never quite seen before.
And I just, I was dying to
see it come to life on screen.
And then after I read the
book, I red Lucy's script,
and I was really excited to work with her
because she just felt like
the perfect screenwriter
to attach to this.
Being from the South
and also being such a
naturally lyrical writer,
she really was able to kind
of channel Delia's voice
into the script and be as
faithful as she could to the book.
So, it was just amazing,
the way that it kind of came full circle.
(light music)
I mean, I think that when I read the book
and thought about the
movie version of the book,
I wanted to make sure
that I captured the emotional experience
that the book takes you
on more than anything.
It's this epic story that
weaves an entire person's life,
and it's heartbreaking,
but it's also hopeful.
There's this driving mystery to it
that kind of keeps you turning the pages
'cause you're dying to
know, did she do it,
didn't she do it?
There are these romances that
are kind of also keep you
at the edge of your seat
to see what's gonna happen
with these different men that she meets.
So I wanted to make sure that the movie
followed that same sort
of emotional journey.
And then, I think what's
the biggest difference
between the movie and the book
is that I had the feeling
that I really wanted
as much as possible for us
to be in Kya's point of view
and to follow the story in her shoes.
I didn't wanna leave her.
And so, rather than have
the courtroom drama happen
towards the end of the movie,
I wanted to weave it throughout.
And so, we set the trial up
right from the beginning.
And so that way, whenever
you're in the present,
you're with Kya on trial
and you're sort of on the
edge of your seat wondering,
"Is she gonna get off or not?"
And then whenever you're
in the past, of course,
you're following her tale of survival
and romance and coming of age.
That differs a bit from
the structure of the book.
(light music)
We had 12 weeks of prep.
The first priority was finding
a spot to build Kya's house.
Because the first priority was making sure
that we could shoot it on location
in a setting where we could
move from inside the house
to outside and we could bring
the marsh into the house.
We didn't wanna have to
shoot her house on a stage.
And I really admire my
production designer Sue Chan,
who found this location in a state park
where when you looked one
direction out into Kya's lagoon,
it really took your breath away.
You really felt like you were in the book
looking out into the kind of landscape
that Kya would have sat at
her lagoon and looked out at.
But when you looked the other way,
it was wide open, there
was this historic house,
the Otis Mansion, right there.
And then there were all
these big live oaks.
And I just said, "Well Sue,
this is never gonna work.
How are we gonna cover all this?"
And she said, "No, no, no,
we're gonna get greens.
We're gonna build the house here
and it's gonna block a certain amount.
And then we're gonna fill in with greens."
And I said, "But what about
the path that Ma walks down?
We have to have a path.
That image from the book was just,
is one of those images
that stays with you."
And she said, "No, no, we're gonna,
we'll use the curve of the
branches of the oak trees
and we'll create this path under them."
So it was just one of those
like cross your fingers
and hope it all works out,
and it was magnificent.
Still, when I watch the movie,
I just sit there going, "I
cannot believe (laughing)
how remote it looks."
The book was definitely our North Star.
We returned to it over and over again
for passages that describe the landscape
because Delia is just
such an amazing writer,
especially when it comes to
capturing nature and wildlife.
And it was important that we find
all of the different
textures to Kya's world.
And then, Barkley Cove, I would say,
was probably the hardest
location for us to recreate.
It just is hard to find towns on the coast
right close to the beach
like that that still exist,
that haven't been developed.
When we decided to shoot
this film in New Orleans,
we were looking for towns
that at least had architecture
that was of the time period
and also felt small enough
that you could imagine a town
where everybody would be
gossiping about the Marsh Girl
and that everybody knew each other
and there was that sort of
sense of an intimate space.
So, we looked at a lot of different towns,
and they just felt too big.
We really looked high and low
for the right kind of town,
and we found it in Houma,
which has these storefronts
that really feel plucked
right out of the '50s.
It feels very untouched.
All we had to do was
really dress the windows,
bring in picture cars,
hide some modernities, but it
was just absolutely perfect
in terms of time period.
(mysterious music)
We couldn't shoot in an actual fire tower.
We couldn't get all of our
equipment up that high.
It wasn't safe.
So we had to build that and
we had to green screen that,
and we actually found a fire tower
that was built in the exact place
where we would imagine this
fire tower would be built,
overlooking the marsh lands,
that wasn't even accessible by road.
It was only accessible by boat.
And so, we went out to
that location with a drone
and we shot plates from
that same fire tower
so that you really felt the right height.
We used it as a model for
the fire tower that we built.
So it's funny because if we could've shot
on the top of that fire
tower, we would've.
I would say, shooting on
boats was really challenging.
Not only because like
anytime you shoot on boats,
your crew is just,
you're a fleet of boats.
You're not one boat.
There's the picture boat, and
then there's the camera boat,
and then there's hair and
makeup is on a different boat,
and props is on, and it's
you're this fleet going out.
But the bayous that we were shooting in,
the water would rise and fall.
And so, there were times
where the waters just fell
to a point where it was too shallow.
So we would go out scouting
and we'd find a location
where we would set the scenes
and we'd, Polly and I would shot list it
in a very specific way based
on what it looked like,
and then the day before
we were set to shoot,
we'd find out the water was too low
and we were gonna have to
find another spot on the day.
And we'd just get out there an
hour before the cast arrived
and be going around in
boats finding a place
that was deep enough,
that sort of still had the
same look that we needed.
So, that was challenging.
(mysterious music continues)
There's so much story to fit into a movie.
Kya's relationship to the marsh
and what she takes from
it is hugely important.
It doesn't have the driving
force of the mystery
and of the romances.
I mean, those are really
kind of what keep you engaged
in the story.
But understanding Kya
as a character requires
that you spend time with her in the marsh,
you spend time with her observing
nature and her drawings.
And so, we had a B
camera unit that went out
and filmed the marsh whenever we knew
we weren't gonna need a second camera.
We were very meticulous
about scheduling days
and looking at when we were
gonna be on certain locations
where we knew you would
be able to get egrets
and great blue herons and make sure
that there was enough time
to get all of that wildlife
so that we could incorporate
it into the film.
And then, for me, one of
the most emotional parts
of the film is the moment that Ma leaves
and it's so vividly described.
I mean, I think it happens
on page one in the book.
I really wanted to make sure
that we got those details across,
the sound of the screen door slamming,
the snakeskin heels,
and her blue suitcase.
Those details that really
just stick in your mind.
You have this image that you can't shake,
and there were things like
that that I just thought,
"We can't ever get those details wrong."
And there was a question
about the vision that Kya has
of her mother, whether it needed
to be in the movie or not,
and to me, it felt like
such an important part
of her whole story arc was
that vision that she has.
And in the book, that was the
moment where I just lost it,
(laughing) and so I
really wanted to make sure
that we captured that.
I mean, the other thing
that was hard to balance
in an adaptation was,
there's so much history
that you learn about
Kya's parents in the book
and where they're from
and trying to figure out
how much of that we
could get into the movie.
And we, I think, where
we tried to layer that in
was through the production design.
Her mother comes from some
money from New Orleans,
and what we imagined when
we were building the house
and designing it was that perhaps
Ma brought some furniture,
had some antiques, and at first tried
to make the house really pretty,
even though it was just
this fishing cabin.
And so, there's peeled wallpaper
that you can imagine Ma put up
and one wall that's painted,
but now the paint is peeling.
And just remnants of a
life that started out there
with hope that her mother
passed onto her this idea
that even if you don't have a lot,
you can take pride in where
you live and what you wear
and you can still take care of yourself
and carry yourself with dignity.
I think was really important
to try to get through.
There's so much in the
dialogue that is a reflection
of the character.
So the way that Kya speaks
when she's a teenager,
before she's learned to read
and before she's really
immersed herself in literature,
is very different from once
she's educated herself.
So, and Delia just does
such an amazing job
with capturing that particular
voice and its evolution.
So, going back to the book
again to look at the way
that Delia did that was important.
And of course, Lucy added
her own embellishments
and sometimes we would
have to add information
that you can describe in
a novel in a different way
than you can have to show in a movie.
And Delia, again, she
created these characters
and really, there's not a
single piece of dialogue
that I'm sure Delia didn't think
about and write and rewrite
for a reason.
And so, as much as we could
honor what she did so well,
we would take directly from
the book, and then, of course,
if things needed to be
changed or altered slightly,
that was in Lucy's wise hands.
Of course, there's a poetry
woven throughout the book,
both in the dialogue and
in Kya's observations.
And whenever we could
use it for the voiceover
or use it in the dialogue
and where it felt natural
and it made sense,
we would always go back
to the source for sure.
(light music continues)